how do you I think he's fake do you
still go to divorce parents home no they
take care of the that's too
confusing Christmas day is kind of like
I don't want to say not that tight but
it's like Naughty Boy uh oh get over
here what the [__] are you saying about
Christmas Day you piece of [__] what the
[__] are you talking about I swear to
God on my life if I wasn't S I wasn't
CHR [__] CR lucky [__] I thought you
were German now you turn Italian i' been
all over for Christ sake he's Mr
worldwide I I'm Mr Mr International my
aunt told me that like Santa's not real
I never even thought he was real I just
remember my parents was like Santa's not
real huh and then I remember my mom
saying something like no but it's nice
[Laughter]
huh oh